se me ocurre hacer otro ejemplo acerca
del mínimo común múltiplo de hecho en
este caso quiero saber cuál es el mínimo
común múltiplo de 20 y 18 y dice otra
forma de ver esto es el mínimo común
múltiplo el mcm de 20 y 18 es y ahorita
ponemos la respuesta así que vamos a
calcularlo vamos a abrir aquí nuestro
pizarrón y vamos a ver los números 20 y
18 y para poder obtener el mínimo común
múltiple entre 20 y 18 lo que voy a
hacer es factorizar a estos números en
primos y para factorizar a estos números
y descomponer los en números primos voy
a hacer un árbol de factorización así
que empecemos con el 20 el 20 lo primero
que me doy cuenta que tiene mitad por lo
tanto vamos a sacarle la mitad a 20 y la
mitad de 2010 por lo tanto 20 lo podemos
escribir como 2 por 10 ahora este 10
también lo podemos factorizar en primos
es lo mismo que 2 por 5 2 por 5 por lo
tanto el 20 lo puedo ver como 2 por 2
por 5 es más no voy a escribir aquí al
20 lo puedo ver como 2 por 2 por 5 esto
cuando hago la descomposición en números
primos del 20 muy bien una vez que ya
trabajamos con el 20 pues vamos a hacer
lo mismo con el 18 el 18 lo voy a
descomponer en primos y lo primero que
me doy cuenta que tiene mitad la mitad
de 18
9 por 2 es 18 pero el 9 el 9 su vez
tiene 3a entonces la tercera de 9 es 3 y
3 es un número primo por lo tanto ya
puedo decir que el número 18 lo puedo
escribir de la siguiente manera déjame
cambiar de color el 18 lo puedo ver como
2 por 3 2 por tres por 3 ok
así ya escribo al 18 factor izando lo en
números primos ya tengo el 20 ya tengo
el 18 y ahora como encuentro el mínimo
común múltiplo entre estos dos bueno
pues el mínimo común múltiplo debe tener
todos los primos del 20 y todos los
primos del 18 de tal manera que pague el
20 para el 18 y nada más es decir que si
yo me fijo en el 20 el 20 es lo mismo
que 2 por 2 por 5
no voy a poner aquí al 20 yo lo formó
multiplicando al 2 por 2
por 5 ok entonces de estos formó al 20
es más lo voy a poner aquí cuando
multiplicados por 2 por 5 obtengo 20
ahora esto por una parte pero por otra
parte tengo que formar también al 18 y
al 18 la forma multiplicando dos por
tres por tres sin embargo y aquí tengo
un 2 tengo este 2 que no servía para
formar al 20 así que lo que nos hace
falta es un 3 y otro 3 por lo tanto dos
por tres por tres
esto me da 18 y yo junto este este y
este de estos 3 puedo formar al número
18 y con esto ya tengo el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 2018 cuando yo puedo
formar tanto al 20 como el 18 en su
descomposición de números primos puedo
afirmar que ya encontré al mínimo común
múltiplo de hecho yo podría multiplicar
por cualquier otra cosa aquí por 5 por
10 por 200 y yo quiero aunque ese número
sea múltiplo en común de estos dos tanto
del 20 como del 18 no sería el mínimo
para encontrar el mínimo
no tiene que sobrar ningún otro factor y
ahora sí cuánto es esto
bueno pues 2 por 2 por 5 pues justo
estos 20 justo así fue como construimos
al 20 y bueno después del 20 si lo
multiplicó por 3 y después por 3 voy a
obtener 9 por 20 es ciento ochenta 180
es decir que el mínimo común múltiplo el
mínimo común múltiplo en esta ocasión
entre 20 y 18 es lo mismo que 180 es
hora de poner nuestro resultado en el
sitio de khan academy la respuesta tiene
que ser 180 y ahora sí vamos a comprobar
la respuesta y estamos bien así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo